bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 6 avril les autorités de belgrade
viennent d'annoncer un cessez-le-feu
unilatéral au kosovo contre les soldats
séparatistes albanais de l'ofce cas les
serbes se déclare prêt à des
négociations avec ibrahim rugova le chef
rebelle des albanais actuellement
retenus à pristina décision insuffisante
pour l'arrêt des frappes selon l'otan à
bruxelles nous dira à son arc il use les
avions de l'otan poursuivent leurs
bombardements à partir de la base
italienne d'aviano se trouve à l'âme
chalvron à 20 heures le président chirac
comme la semaine passée s'adresse aux
français en direct sur la situation au
kosovo
le sort des réfugiés peut-être 500 voire
700 milles en macédoine au monténégro et
en albanie sera évoquée par nos envoyés
spéciaux
jérôme mounaris bureau benoît duquesne
et bertrand cocq la france ne ferme pas
ses portes aux réfugiés albanais ce fut
cet après midi la mise au point de
lionel jospin devant les députés à
l'assemblée nationale
c'est donc à la radio officielle serbe
et à la télévision de belgrade que les
gouvernements de la république fédérale
de yougoslavie de la république serbe
annonçait il y a moins de trois heures
qu'il décrétait un cessez-le-feu
unilatéral au kosovo contre les
séparatistes albanais voici les
conditions de cette annonce commentée
par philippe visseyrias c'est au milieu
du journal de la radio-télévision serbe
à 17h peu l'annoncé du cessez-le-feu a
été fait il s'agit d'un communiqué de 2
minutes 30 lui par une journaliste serbe
dont voici le résumé
premièrement à l'occasion des fêtes de
la pâque orthodoxe la yougoslavie
décrète un cessez-le-feu unilatéral on
retrouve à partir de ce soir 20 heures
toutes les opérations de l'armée et de
la police
entre l'armée de libération du kosovo
sont suspendus deuxièmement toujours
d'après la présentatrice du journal le
gouvernement yougoslave va engager des
discussions avec ibrahim rugova le
représentant de la communauté albanaise
pour préparer un accord provisoire au
kosovo celui ci sera suivi par un accord
définitif d'autonomie du kosovo au sein
de la république serbe et de la
fédération yougoslave
troisièmement en compagnie du
représentant des albanais ibrahim rugova
gouvernement yougoslave soit préparé un
plan de retour des réfugiés
aidé en cela par le haut commissariat
aux réfugiés des nations unies et par le
comité international de la croix rouge
direct monsieur communiqué le ministre
de l'information serbe
monsieur le ministre bonsoir les
réactions sont plutôt négatives on
estime que c'est insuffisant pour que
les frappes de l'otan s'arrête alors
comment pouvez-vous vous pouvez vous
prouver votre bonne foi que pensez vous
de cette réaction négative
écoutez tout d'abord nous nous nous
adressons aux albanais d'abord pour
réanimer les dialogues entre eux et nous
c'est le premier pas et nous ne sont pas
étonnés par les comportements et par la
réaction de washington et de l'otan
qu'ils continuent leurs activités
nous avons démontré encore une fois
notre aptitude à obtenir à aboutir la
paix dans la région de kosovo les mêmes
demain 2 mais nous aurions aussi des
témoignages et de bons signes de bonne
volonté par rapport aux albanais et par
rapport à la population du kosovo mais
monsieur communiste pour faire la paix
pour un cessez le feu le signer avec vos
adversaires pourquoi pas avec checa tout
d'abord ce sont des extrémistes qui qui
provoque et qui provoque des actions
militaires et policiers au kosovo s'il
s'agit de la population albanaise est
calme nous n'aurions pas de problème ni
des motifs à réagir ce sont des
terroristes qui ont provoqué cette crise
est celle autant avec le bombardier qui
a augmenté cette crise est aussi
transformer la crise dans une
catastrophe
alors monsieur milosevic est il paraphé
cette décision de cessez le feu parce
qu'il semble qu'il ait été absent de la
de la réunion il a été absent bien sûr
il suffit que des gouvernements le
gouvernement fédérale yougoslave et le
gouvernement de la république de serbie
on adopter cette déclaration en partant
de l'accord du président milosevic et de
monsieur rugova énoncés dans la
déclaration commune
il ya six jours pourquoi ne pas ajouter
à ce cessez le feu unilatéral un retrait
des forces serbes pour peut-être
permettre des négociations plus larges
dès que la sécurité pour tout le monde
là bas kosovo sera garanti alors nous
sommes prêts tout de suite à retirer nos
forces mais s'il faut faire cette faute
comme l'année précédente quand nous
avons retiré nos forces policières et de
l'armée tous lui tout cas à pénétrer a
envoyé le kosovo et ils sont commis des
atrocités contre les musulmans serbes
turquie etc etc
et pour l'instant les atrocités sont
surtout constaté du que de votre côté on
parle d' atrocités commises par la
police serbe par les miliciens serbes et
qu il faut se demander d'abord qui a
constaté ces réfugiés des réfugiés
albanais monsieur le ministre des
réfugiés albanais fut juillet oui ce
sont elles qui elle même les enfants
albanais notamment qui ont vu leur part
entre élus qui ont été invités le plus
souvent par utaka et partent hadji qui
le fonds s'est mise à saint côme le
prétexte la libye pour les bombardiers
américains et européens contre la serbie
et la yougoslavie comme un pays
souverain
vous passez des réfugiés albanais
peuvent inventer des meurtres des
assassinats écoutez quand il s'agit de
la guerre c'est sous les bombes de
l'otan que les atrocités ont été
augmentés et la crise est maintenant
pratiquement une catastrophe personne ne
peut pas contrôler nous avons les
policiers armés là-bas pour contrôler la
situation s'il est possible nous ne
chassons les albanais nous avons un
grand intérêt ce départ de sauvegarder
des saules et d'arrêter les albanais
qu'il keep mais il y à des albanais qui
pratiquement simule une catastrophe pour
donner le prétexte elle aussi les
journalistes
américain qui comme christiane en cours
réagissent d'une manière absolument
intolérable qui est augmentée qui gonfle
la situation redoutez-vous de nouveaux
bombardements encore plus violent que la
nuit dernière
écoutez tout d'abord nous attendons tous
qui peut nous dire que les bombardements
du nombre de pays la dette destruction
de ponts de chemin de fer et tous à 400
500 kilomètres loin de kosovo est-ce que
ça a été provoqué par ces soucis des
sauvegardes et les pauvres albanais de
résoudre la crise ou non
nous attendons cette nuit comme l'année
la nuit précédant les bombardements
terrible féroce avec des victimes
civiles conte à l'année près comme la
nuit précédant alexina une petite ville
de serbie où nous avons eu des dizaines
de victimes civiles
bercy n'a pas chers compatriotes comme
je l'avais dit la semaine dernière
je voudrais faire à nouveau le point
avec vous sur la situation au kosovo
l'horreur voulue et organisée par
milosevic dépasse aujourd'hui tout ce
que l'on peut imaginer
en accord avec le gouvernement
je vous redis que ce n'est pas
acceptable
des centaines de milliers de kosovars
ont été chassés vers l'albanie le
monténégro ou la macédoine
contrairement à ce que dit la propagande
du dictateur ils n'ont pas fui pour
échapper aux frappes de l'otan'' ils ont
fui et tous en témoigne unanimement
devant les soldats et les miliciens
serbes qui les chassent sous menace de
mort après leur avoir tout pris
il s'agit là d'une monstrueuse opération
d'épuration ethnique planifiée et
conduite avec le plus grand cynisme et
la plus grande cruauté par le régime
serbe
l'aide humanitaire est à l'heure
progressivement dans l'ensemble de la
région
la france il prend toute sa part je
voudrais rendre hommage à tous ceux
civile militaire volontaire des
organisations humanitaires qui se
mobilisent avec coeur avec compétence et
je veux aussi vous rendre hommage à vous
qui par des gestes personnel exprimez
votre générosité
mais nous devons faire davantage
d'abord pour les réfugiés
faut-il un envisager leur transfert dans
les pays occidentaux
je ne crois pas que cela soit la
solution même si elle donne l'impression
d'être celle du coeur
ce nouvel exode refusé d'ailleurs para
la plupart d'entre eux conduirait à les
éloigner plus encore de leur terre des
villages et des villes où ils ont le
droit de revenir et de vivre librement
et en paix nous devons bien sûr prendre
en compte les situations exceptionnelles
les situations de plus grande détresse
et sur la base d'un volontariat
clairement exprimée mais nous ne vont
rien accepter qui puisse faire le jeu de
milosevic dont l'ambition est clairement
de chasser les kosovars définitivement
et le plus loin possible de chez eux
perspective qui est précisément combattu
par les forces alliées au nom de la
morale
et des droits de l'homme pour être
efficace notre solidarité de s'exprimer
aussi à l'égard des pays qui accueille
ses réfugiés l'albanie la macédoine le
monténégro
seul un véritable plan d'urgence peut
leur permettre de surmonter les
difficultés économiques et financières
qui les assaillent j'ai proposé cet
après midi au chancelier allemand
gerhard schröder qui préside
actuellement l'union européenne de faire
de notre prochain conseil européen le 14
avril un conseil exceptionnel destiné à
prendre
les nouvelles mesures qui s'imposent
mais c'est légitime préoccupation
humanitaire ne doivent pas nous faire
oublier la nécessité de poursuivre notre
effort militaire
je vous ai dit il ya quelques jours que
cette action demanderait du temps et de
la détermination
je le répète aujourd'hui les frappes
engagées contre le régime serbe ont pour
objectif la destruction des moyens dont
il dispose pour chasser les kosovars par
la terreur et par le crime
jour après jour l'action des alliés
conduite à l'étouffement progressif de
cet appareil militaire serbe
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
sommes attaqués aux dispositifs de
commandement au moyen de communication à
certains points stratégiques ou dépôts
de carburant nous l'avons fait en
prenant soin d'éviter au maximum les
dommages civile
ces frappes doivent se poursuivre
notamment sur les forces militaires
jusqu'à ce que ce régime cesse sa
répression criminelle et permette
réellement le retour chez eux des
réfugiés ou alors jusqu'à ce qu'ils
n'aient plus les moyens de poursuivre
ces funestes desseins
je veux croire que le peuple serve pour
lequel nous n'avons qu'estimé amitié
ouvrira enfin les yeux sur la réalité de
son j
dans le même temps il appartient aux
européens ou aux américains et russes
sous l'autorité de l'onu le souhaite de
rechercher les voies d'un accord
politique assurant la stabilité et la
paix dans une partie de l'europe qui a
vocation à rejoindre le moment venu
notre union européenne je veux vous dire
ce soir que l'action menée par mir évite
ch ne triomphera pas la barbarie ne peut
avoir le dernier mot
la justice doit passer et les criminels
devront rendre des comptes
les européens unis les alliés unis
doivent poursuivre leur mission ils le
feront jusqu'à son terme notre ambition
d'un coup chevaux où chacun pourra vivre
en paix demeure entière
notre ambition d'une solution politique
demeure le fondement de notre action en
plein accord avec le gouvernement
je voudrais dire aux autorités aux
autorités serbes que le cessez le feu
qu'elle semble envisagée est
indispensable mais insuffisant dans le
cadre d'un accord politique
il doit impérativement s'accompagner de
l'ensemble des mesures permettant un
retour effectif de la paix et de la
sécurité au kosovo
le chaton patriotes en terminant je
voudrais exprimer en notre nom à tous au
nom de la nation réunit une pensée des
steam et de reconnaissance à nos soldats
et à tous les soldats alliés qui
participent aux opérations pour
l'appeler et pour le droit dans les
balkans donc pour l'intervention de
monsieur jacques chirac vous prédire
vouloir excuser le caractère un peu
brutale du passage de l'utérus nous
étions en train de réaliser avec
monsieur comédie chemise soit servi
l'information et l'intervention du
président de la république qui a
souhaité comme la semaine dernière faire
oeuvre de pédagogie et expliquer
pourquoi il faut maintenir la mission
actuellement poursuivis par les forces
alliées de l'otan en citant l'horreur
voulue par monsieur milosevic n'est pas
acceptable et l'offre de cessez-le-feu
fait l' annonce de cessez-le-feu fait en
fin d'après midi car les cernes est
indispensable mais insuffisant car il
faut maintenant revenir plus en détail
sur ce geste entre guillemets du
président milosevic et de son
gouvernement
l'annnonce du cessez-le-feu se complète
en effet d'un plan de négociation avec
monsieur rue gauvin le chef me direz les
albanais dont on peut penser qu'il n'est
pas totalement libre après stinat sous
la protection entre guillemets de la
police serbe
l'explication eric monier toutes les
actions contre l'armée agressive de
libération du kosovo seront interrompus
à 20h à l'occasion de la grande fête
chrétienne orthodoxe la pac c'est un
communiqué commun des gouvernements de
la république fédérale et de celle de
serbie qu'ils en ont plus tard le vice
premier ministre yougoslave vu que
draskovic précise que toutes les troupes
serbes stationnés au kosovo regagneront
leurs casernes avant l'entrée en vigueur
de la trêve dans son communiqué belgrade
propose aussi un plan de retour des
réfugiés
en collaboration avec le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés de l'onu
et le comité international de la croix
quant au plan d'autonomie du kosovo
autre proposition annoncée cet après
midi pour en discuter
belgrade choisi son interlocuteur
ibrahim rugova le leader des modérés
albanais et président élu d'un
gouvernement parallèle à pristina
gouvernement jamais reconnue par la
serbie ibrahim rugova chef non violent
et pacifiste est loin d'être un contesté
dans son propre camp il était réapparu à
la télévision de serbie à plusieurs
reprises après des jours de silence ses
appels à l'arrêt des bombardements selon
belgrade avait surpris au point de le
penser manipulés voire otage de
milosevic ou aujourd'hui belgrade tente
d'en faire son seul interlocuteur pour
évoquer l'avenir du kosovo
dès mercredi écartant tous les autres
négociateurs des réunions de rambouillet
de paris et en particulier la résistance
armée ou checa l'armée de libération du
kosovo
voyons maintenant pour les réactions
réunion négative du côté de l'otan jean
marc loos
écoutez n'y a pas encore de réaction
officielle parce que le secrétaire
général le temps sera vielles cela
n'allait pas seul maître à bord il doit
consulter les 19 membres de l'alliance
et en particulier les membres du groupe
de contact sur la yougoslavie c'est à
dire les quatre européens la russie et
les etats unis
on n'attend pas du tout vous en doutez
une réponse positive tout simplement
comme l'a rappelé tout à l'heure jacques
chirac parce que les propositions de
monsieur me de ces niches ne répondent
nullement aux trois critères fixés par
l'otan et rappelait encore cet après
midi même par le porte parole de l'otan
à savoir cessation des hostilités contre
les civils avec retrait de l'armée serbe
deuxièmement possibilité de retour mais
sous protection internationale armée
pour les réfugiés ce que refuse
monsieur milosevic troisièmement prise
en compte du cadre de l'accord de
rambouillet alors ce que l'on peut
prédire sans trop pouvoir se tromper ce
soir c'est que ces trois points n'étant
pas respecté
on peut prédire que les frappes
aériennes vont se poursuivre comme prévu
ce soir sur la yougoslavie
merci jean marc ce soir à moscou un
conseiller du président boris eltsine
indiqué que la russie espérait que cette
proposition de belgrade serait un tour
dans la crise et que le cessez le feu
est une chance que les occidentaux
doivent saisir
il ne faut pas laisser passer cette
chance a dit monsieur ivanoff le
ministre des affaires étrangères russe
aux etats unis philippe gassot même
réaction qu'à l'otan oui ce qui est sûr
ici c'est que les américains vont pas se
contenter de demi-mesures avec milosevic
ce sera du tout ou rien s'il accepte de
retourner à la case départ avec ses
troupes de s'asseoir à la table de
négociation et de reprendre le dossier
père oui mais les choses vont pouvoir
s'arranger
faute de quoi les bombardements vont se
poursuivre alors quid de la réaction de
l'opinion publique américaine à cette
persistance de l'action des américains
au sein de l'otan eh bien vous avez 55 %
des américains qui sont derrière bill
clinton même si celui-ci doit disposer
deux mains des troupes au sol et vous
avez un peu plus de 40% de ces
américains qui se pose pas mal de
questions notamment des questions
politiques après les bombardements
il pense que bill clinton n'a pas en
main des justifications politiques il
pense que bill clinton a largement
minimisé le rôle de milosevic minimiser
aussi le nombre de jours de
bombardements qu'il fallait et en ce qui
concerne le dossier humanitaire ils
comprennent mal ses opposants un bill
clinton que l'otan souhaite aller
frapper pour des raisons justement
humanitaire et qu'il voit sur tous les
écrans du monde des cohortes de miséreux
traversée donc ces écrans de télévision
alors que on leur a promis que l'otan
était là pour défendre la veuve et
l'orphelin
il se demande si le remède n'est pas
pire que le mal merci philippe et pour
preuve de la volonté de l'otan de
maintenir l'action militaire l'aviation
des pays engagés dans le conflit a
continué ses décollages aujourd'hui
depuis la base d'aviano vous vous
trouvez en chevrons oui écouter l'otan
ne parle peut-être pas mais agit à 18h15
c'est à dire une heure et quart à peu
près après que la serbie ait fait cet
appel cessez le feu et bien les avions
décoller un groupe important décollé de
la base d'aviano devant les caméras du
monde entier
avec le message fasse clairement cinq
sur cinq de l'autre côté de l'adriatique
un groupe de seize 16 avec son groupe
logistique en particulier les avions de
brouillage électronique
et puis aussi les chasseurs bombardiers
les plus puissants de l'armée de l'air
américaine
les f 15 noeuds tous ces appareils comme
vous le voyez étant chargé jusqu'à la
gueule de bombes et missiles diverses
alors bien sûr rien ne prouve que ces
appareils héron larguer leurs
chargements sur le kosovo mais tout est
fait pour le croire en tout cas ici à la
base d'aviano en ce moment même se
trouve le chef d'état major général de
l'armée américaine le général shelton
pour bien faire preuve de la
détermination des états unis merci à
philippe rochot est ce qu'on peut dire
trivialement que c'est une sorte de coup
de bluff de monsieur milosevic
écoutez en décrétant un cessez-le-feu
unilatéral belgrade savait déjà qu'il ne
serait pas acceptée par les pays de
l'otan dont les exigences restent les
mêmes retrait des forces serbes et
signature des accords de rambouillet qui
prévoit l'installation d'une force de
paix internationale au kosovo belgrade
parle de cessez le feu contre les
terroristes de l'ue ces cas mais se
garde bien de citer les exactions des
forces serbes paramilitaire contre les
population albanaise slobodan milosevic
tente de gagner du temps de voir si des
pays sceptiques comme la grèce vont
accepter son geste il sème la confusion
en essayant de récupérer politiquement
le chef des albanais modéré ibrahim
rugova qui apparemment n'est pas libre
de ses mouvements et ils essayent d'en
faire un allié contre la politique des
pays de l'otan alors les bombardements
continuent encore sans doute ce soir
cette nuit de manière très intensive
mais on a l'impression qu'on s'approche
de plus en plus deux avec une offensive
terrestre
oui les politiques refusent toujours ce
scénario mais en s'y prépare surtout
qu'au rythme de l'exode il ne restera
plus d'albanais ou cousseau vous dans
trois semaines
l'objectif est de faire revenir les
réfugiés du kosovo dans leur village en
dégageant au moins une zone à couloirs
protégés
on parle aussi de mettre en avant les
combattants de l'ue sekkaki
symboliquement repartirait à la conquête
du kosovo avec le soutien militaire des
pays d'autan bien sûr mais dans tous les
cas de figure on arriverait en fait un
partage du kosovo entre serbes et
albanais ont aussi fini
les frappes engagées en territoire serve
par les avions de l'otan ont été
particulièrement sévère la nuit dernière
les dégâts matériels sont très
importants mais on signale également et
peut-être pour la première fois depuis
le début des frappes le 24 mars un
nombre de victimes civiles importantes
commentaires françois cornet base alliée
d'aviano hier 13e lui de frappe pour les
chasseurs bombardiers de l'otan
première cible touchée par des missiles
cette raffinerie de pétrole brut dans
les quartiers est de novi sad au nord de
la serbie il est un peu plus 22 heures
l'adc a va riposter sans conséquence
pour les avions de l'alliance objective
de ce raid contre des plus importantes
raffineries du pays privé n'a servi de
carburant et stopper le ravitaillement
des transports de troupes et des blindés
yougoslave officiellement l'otan n'est
toujours à la phase de ses opérations de
bombardement qui consiste à affaiblir au
maximum le potentiel militaire et ses
approvisionnements
dans ce cadre des relais de transmission
été détruits de même que plusieurs ponts
dont celui ci à novi sad le dernier pont
dans la ville enjambant le danube
les deux autres avaient été détruits ces
derniers jours il s'agit pour la
violence dans renier les mouvements de
troupes vers le kosovo en coupant le sud
de la voïvodine au nord riche en pétrole
et grenier à blé ou maïs de la
yougoslavie
cinq villes de serbie ont été bombardés
la nuit dernière dont une cité minière
de 30000 habitants
alexine accès au centre de la serbie
touchée par trois missiles l'otan n'a
délivré aucune information sur le choix
de cette cible civile dans laquelle sept
personnes au moins auraient trouvé la
mort
les bombardiers en fait se serait trompé
de cible
l'objectif visé aurait été une caserne
abritant la 203ème brigade d'artillerie
serbe
un responsable de l'alliance a reconnu
que cette bavure pourraient être
imputables au guidage défaillant d'un
missile notons que c'est la première
fois depuis le début du conflit que
l'otan reconnaît que l'une de ses armes
a pu provoquer des morts et des blessés
dans la population civile outre ses
morts et ses blessés d'alexina tué au
sud de belgrade selon l'ambassadeur de
yougoslavie à moscou c'est le propre
frère du président milosevic
les bombardements de l'otan aurait fait
300 morts et 3000 blessés bilan
évidemment invérifiable
tout comme il est exclu que les frappes
de l'otan ne fasse que des dégâts
matériels
commentaire rommel venant margaret
albright bill clinton ou encore tony
blair recherché comme criminel de guerre
ces images sont diffusées sur de
nombreux sites de l'internet contrôlée
par les autorités serbes car la guerre
du kosovo a conquis un autre champ de
bataille celui de l'information et
notamment autour d'un thème les victimes
de l'otan de son côté la télévision
serbe n'a pas tardé non plus la diffuser
les images d'alexina une petite ville à
200 km au sud de belgrade dont un
quartier a été dévastée par les
bombardements de l'alliance lundi soir
des bombardements qui aurait tué au
moins sept civils blessés 26 autres et
des prix une vingtaine de maisons
j'étais assis dans mon fauteuil
et tout d'un coup il ya eu une explosion
une explosion terrible j'ai été projeté
à terre à plus d'un mètre
on voit le mention de l'hôtel sur
l'efficacité de leur arme soi-disant
précise un bombardement que l'otan
appelle une erreur d'impact une erreur
de guidage car le missile devait
s'abattre en fait sur la thaïlande
thaksin
il est possible que la nominer les rater
sa cible ce malgré un plan d'aste
méticuleux et malgré les statistiques
très élevé réussi des tirs gamestop
de leur côté les rares journalistes
serbe indépendants comme ceux de bêta
presse cherche tant bien que mal à
recouper leurs informations sur le
nombre exact de victimes après 13 jours
de guerre je n'entends pas que les
médias occidentaux croient même à
quelqu'un qui se dit comme nous
indépendant d'ici dix de nos quoi 100%
que l'otan peut dire encore une fois oui
mais
il était près d'un aéroport où ils
étaient près d'un père cibles militaires
ça n'empêche que c'était les villages où
les maisons des primes et enfin de
priver des gens ordinaires
samarth le ministre russe de la défense
avait parlé de 1000 victimes parmi les
civils aujourd'hui l'ambassadeur de
yougoslavie à mouscou ramène le chiffre
à 300 des bilans impossibles à vérifier
en direct de belgrade maintenant avec
nous notre consoeur de radio france
internationale catherine monnet
catherine monin quelle est la réaction
de la population dans la capitale serbe
après l'annnonce du cessez-le-feu 7 par
le gouvernement de belgrade
écoutez ici la moindre perspective d'un
règlement pacifique du conflit suscite
toujours un espoir ça a été le cas
lorsqu'il ya eu la médiation russe et le
cas encore ce soir
tout simplement parce que la population
civile est de plus en plus directement
affectées par les bombardements de
l'otan tous contente plus donc depuis
quelques jours de frapper des cibles
purement militaire et voies de
communication commence à être coupés les
usines sont détruites les bombardements
tous maintenant les centres villes il
n'y a plus de 100 heures les gens savent
ils savent aussi que les frappes ne sont
donc pas toujours chirurgicale en
l'espace de trois jours il ya quand même
eu ce que l'otan appelle pudiquement
deux erreurs techniques et il ya donc de
plus en plus de victimes civiles alors
certes je dirais qu'il ya toujours un
esprit de défi a un qui règne dans le
pays la volonté de résistance est
toujours entière mais quand même la
population subit de plus en plus le
stress de la guerre et les gens ont tout
simplement peur de plus en plus peur
même est ce qu'il y a des conséquences
directes dans l'organisation dans la vie
politique où ddd mener un peu
extrémistes dans un belgrade
alors effectivement la perdre et dans
des bombes est une chose mais il ya
aussi une inquiétude croissante sur la
façon dont évolue gérer la situation
interne on le voit bien à l'occasion des
différentes manifestations qui se
tiennent un peu partout à travers la
serbie
de plus en plus ce sont les partisans
ultras nationalistes de voice tracer
shell et les anciens communistes qui
prennent le haut du pavé ce son si vous
voulez les forces brunes et rousses qui
existaient de fatma matin dans le pays
mais qui ressorte et qui s'imposent et
puis la situation permet au pouvoir de
prendre des décrets inquiétant par
exemple dernier en date
c'est que la police ce mal an
perquisitionné n'importe où n'importe
quand sans mandat avec de telles mesures
on peut donc très vite ont baissé la
situation continue de se dégrader dans
une sorte d'anarchie qui permettra à
chacun de régler les vieux comptes du
passé et notamment avec les opposants du
pouvoir
merci catherine monnet nous allons nous
rendre maintenant au monténégro en
macédoine est d'abord en albanie pour
évoquer la situation des centaines de
milliers de réfugiés le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés n'hésitez pas
à citer le chiffre de 900 mille
personnes déplacées benoît duquesne vous
êtes à accous kesha frontières de
l'albanie et du kosovo quelle a été la
réaction après l'annoncé à proposition
sert de cessez-le-feu unilatéral ciré à
son il y a d'ailleurs écouter pour être
tout à fait franc vers 5 heures nous
avons quitté la frontière avec des dents
pour venir ici assuré le reportage que
vous verrez tout à l'heure donc je n'ai
pas eu le temps encore d'aller
questionner les kosovars qui sont
réfugiées ici qu'ils essaient de dormir
ailleurs partout dans la ville pour
savoir leur réaction à cette annonce de
cessez-le-feu ce que je peux vous dire
en revanche c'est que cet après midi
encore dans les villes enfin les
villages
immédiatement derrière la frontière et
est en feu et ça n'était pas le fait des
bombardements de longtemps je peux vous
dire aussi que depuis maintenant dix
douze jours nous recueillons les
témoignages qui sont terribles de la
part de ces réfugiés qu' aucun d'entre
eux ne semble vouloir maintenant
accorder le moindre crédit à la parole
de milosevic et chaque fois je leur ai
posé la question sur le point de savoir
si les imaginer une vie ailleurs
maintenant en albanie ou même dans un
pays européen
tous m'ont toujours dit nous nous
imaginons qu'un retour au pays que vivre
sur la terre de nos ancêtres là où nous
avons vécu mais nous l'imaginons
maintenant s'en laissait bref les serbes
sans la présence des services n'est plus
question que nous puissions vivre avec
le merci bonnement et c'est donc parmi
les réfugiés albanais près de coke est
ce que vous avez benoît duquesne et
didier deshamps recueilli des
témoignages concordants sur les
exactions et les meurtres imputés aux
milices et policère procédant au vidage
du territoire du kosovo ce matin dans le
temps italien de la sécurité civile
la queue se forme déjà devant l'hôpital
d'urgence à l'intérieur une scène
presque rassurante celle d'un enfant
malade car médecins n'arrivent pas à
faire boire et que sa famille essaie de
convaincre
il s'appelle grain et la 10 ans il est
arrivé hier soir de giacomo djakovica en
serbe et son histoire est terrifiante
donc il était dans une cave
quatre familles il n'y avait que des
femmes et des enfants les hommes étaient
partis
peut-être jaloux chacun pas ça on sait
pas du tout ce sont les hommes lamely
serbe est arrivé ils ont fait sortir
tout le monde ils sont montés au premier
étage et devant l'enfant et ils ont tué
tous un par un avec un pistolet devant
le bar le petit garçon lui l'a récupéré
une balle dans le bras est resté sa
petite soeur qui était vivant puisqu'il
en épargne toujours souverain
ils ont mis le feu à la maison et comme
lui il a fait le fera éclater avec les
structures ouvertes du braille essayer
d'aller chercher cette soupe de serre
est il à paris siège à la partie donc il
a vu tout le monde au rythme effréné
on a été récupéré par son oncle et sa
tante et il est arrivé en face de son
lit sadry quatre ans lui c'est un exode
porter qui lui a arraché une partie de
la jambe il s'enfuyait en tracteur avec
sa famille
la plupart sont morts avec la vue au
niveau 2 de la jambe avec une énorme
énorme play qui fait tout l'arrière de
la jambe avec une très grosse grosse
perte de substance il va je pense je
pense qu'il peut guérir mais il faudrait
la chirurgie plastique parce qu'il ya
une énorme paire de silencieux
je sais pas ce qu'ils vont pouvoir faire
ici mais on va pas pouvoir tout les
anglais en français
et ce ne sont que deux histoires parmi
d'autres une multitude d'autres plus ou
moins atroce terrible insoutenable des
milliers de témoignages pour des
milliers de réfugiés circonstancié
concordants détaillé et qui racontent
tous le même drame la déportation
massive d'un peuple son humiliation la
violence ait ce flou s'écoule doucement
à la frontière pendant que leurs
villages brûle les kosovars abandonne un
pays dans les tracteurs douleur toujours
plus de femmes de vieillards d'enfants
et toujours - dell nous ont maltraité
sur la route ils nous ont forcés à
descendre pour me frapper et les
témoignages sont si forts que les ong
elles mêmes ont commencé à les collecter
comme cet homme qui raconte avoir vu le
cadavre d'une femme enceinte une balle
dans la tête et un poteau dans le vendre
retour près du clan des italiens rennes
et sadri vont être héliporté vers
l'hôpital de tirana
ceux qui deviendront par la suite
personne ne le sait leur avenir est en
pointillé comme le kosovo macédoine à
présent à blatche et jérôme monique
quelle est la réaction j'ai pu
recueillir des réfugiés après le geste
de monsieur milosevic est ici à blatche
et les réfugiés sont sous le choc comme
en albanie
donc dans l'état actuel des choses ils
ne peuvent pas faire confiance aux
serbes
ils craignent les actions de ces
paramilitaires il y en a qui sont venus
volontairement et puis beaucoup d'autres
qui ont été chassés de chez eux par des
paramilitaires donc ils veulent tous
comme ceux qui sont réfugiés en albanais
ils veulent tous reprendre le chemin du
kosovo mais vous voyez que pour
l'instant on en est loin tous écart
continue de prendre des centaines de
réfugiés
il y en a des milliers par jour qui sont
éloignés de la frontière
alors ces réfugiés en fait la seule
façon de les ramener chez eux de
répondre à leurs souhaits ce serait
sinon de vider le kosovo des serbes qui
habite en tout cas au moins de faire
partir les paramilitaires et puis
d'avoir bien sûr là bas au kosovo une
force d'interposition puisque comme ils
l'ont toujours dit les frappes aériennes
ne font que mettre de l'huile sur
feu mais il nous faut nous des témoins
internationaux et plus que des
journalistes qui eux aussi sont des
rendez vous le savez il nous faut une
force d'interposition pour permettre de
vivre normalement et est de pouvoir là
bas dans leur pays reprend dans ses
visions il y en a qui y en a qui n'ont
pas été détruites
il ya certaines maisons qui reste est
ici le seul souhait de de tous ceux qui
se réfugient dans ce village de blatche
et c'est de pouvoir effectivement comme
ceux qui sont réfugiés en albanie
revivre le plus tôt possible au kosovo
merci jérôme est dans le camp de blatche
et c'est à 20 km au nord de skopies y
est vous avez pu constater avec andrei
saura que les efforts des organisations
humanitaires commençait à devenir
efficace peu à peu les milliers de
personnes entassées dans des conditions
épouvantables sont évacués elle met en
oeuvre toute sa force de conviction
maternelle pour que les soldats
macédoniens laisse passer en priorité
ses quatre enfants vers un destin
inconnu
elles savent ce qu'elles fuient pas ce
qu'elles vont trouver des milliers
d'autres vont passer encore une nuit
dans ce vallon au bord de la rivière
sans retour
la vie s'y organise une partie des
réfugiés de ce camp de fortune n'est pas
pressé de partir de s'éloigner de cette
terre du kosovo à laquelle ils sont
encore à dos et ils entendent les
nouvelles d'évacuation vers la norvège
et la turquie
mais eux ne survivent qu avec l'espoir
de rentrer un jour dans leur pays
vous pouvez vous imaginer qu'un homme
dans ma condition travail toute sa vie
pour construire sa maison
soudain quelqu'un arrive et vous dit
vous n'avez pas le droit de rester ici
laissé toutes vos affaires et allez au
diable intra macédonien vient
régulièrement ramassées des tonnes
d'ordures les sanitaires s'installe les
distributions de vivres sont permanentes
mais encore insuffisante
les naufragés de la guerre prennent leur
mal en patience
maintenant c'est très dur de retourner
au kosovo
nous essayons d'aller en macédoine dans
quelques jours nous espérons que ça ira
mieux au kosovo et que nous pourrons
rentrer chez nous d'autres ont décidé de
profiter de l'ouverture de la frontière
depuis hier pour partir la mort dans
l'âme
nous ne pouvons plus supporter de rester
ici
nous avons décidé de partir mais nous ne
savons pas où vous espérer retourner au
free zone oui oui nous voulons tous
retourner au kosovo car c'est notre pays
fatima part avec ce désespoir ancrée en
elle un désespoir qu'elle ne pourra
effacer qu'en retournant chez elle mais
pour l'instant il lui faut affronter les
formalités de la police macédonienne
la macédoine a donc continué d'évacuer
les réfugiés souvent à marche forcée un
pont aérien vers des pays d'accueil est
mis en place souvent dans
l'improvisation mais également avec
quelques brutalité commentaires nathalie
moisan
il n'aura pas le choix embarqué contre
son gré direction la turquie
l'arme d'épuisement et de révolte
évacuation musclée organisée par les
autorités de skopje en gants et masques
blancs mesures de prévention ou méfiance
à l'égard de réfugiés perçus comme des
pestiférés le deuxième exil des kosovars
celui qui les conduit hors des balkans a
commencé hier soir pour la macédoine qui
a déjà reçu 120 mille personnes ces
réfugiés représentent un danger
politique il faut s'en débarrasser
quito besoin à leur cacher leur
destination finale
nous ne savons même pas où nous allons
personne ne nous le dit où est ce qu'on
va et pour éviter toute révolte celle
les autorités demandent aux journalistes
de ne pas répondre à ces réfugiés pour
ceux qui ont compris
l'amertume est grande pourquoi
devons-nous quitter notre pays
nous sommes nés ici nous avons grandi
ici maintenant on nous force à partir on
ne veut pas aller en turquie
on veut rentrer à la maison on veut
retourner vivre dans nos maisons kosovo
des évacuations forcées désapprouvé ce
matin par le commissaire européen aux
affaires humanitaires
les gens ne veulent pas s'éloigner moi
je trouve d'ajouter l'exil forcé à la
déportation forcée ça déjà je trouve
comme qui va pas résoudre la situation
1500 réfugiés déplacés sont ainsi
arrivés en turquie le plus souvent des
femmes et des enfants séparée du reste
de leur famille 600 autres ont gagné la
norvège choisis sur quels critères
mystère dans ces deux pays ils vont
rejoindre des camps pour une durée
indéterminée
les macédoniens estime à 130 mille le
nombre de réfugiés que ce vin sur leur
territoire et le gouvernement de skopje
conteste ce soir les comptes rendus de
la presse étrangère sur l'improvisation
du départ des albanais beaucoup de ceux
ci vont être des dirigés vers
l'allemagne qui s'est déclarée prête à
l'accueillir
40000 reportage valérie fournioux et
frédéric basket
il vient de quitter l'enfer du cloaque
de la frontière où s'entassent encore
plus de dix mille personnes dans ce camp
de transit
la vie reprend ses droits enfin et tout
s'organise en files d'attentes pour
téléphoner donner aussi un de ses
nouvelles pour manger surtout même si
l'on vous sert avec les doigts c'est le
fils de la survie que l'on vous tend un
bien précieux un bonheur pour certains
puis en début d'après-midi les aime de
l'ouest et eu des observateurs
internationaux sont venus organiser les
évacuations en un quart d'heure une
nouvelle file s'était formée pour
inscrire un nom bas d'une liste
destination la norvège et l'allemagne en
priorité les familles et les familles
nombreuses et ensuite ensuite la plage
parmi eux une famille de christina un
couple et leurs quatre enfants qui
veulent partir pour la norvège
en fait je n'ai pas le choix j'aimerais
retourner au kosovo surtout je
préfèrerais aller au kosovo y retourner
mais les conditions de vie sont
tellement excécrable ici et en allemagne
en norvège
qu'allons nous faire nous n'avons rien
c'est comme si les kosovars
elle est à nouveau être séparés en fait
ils partiront pour l'allemagne faute de
place mais peu importe je n'ai que 16
ans mais j'ai vu les films sur ce que
hitler a c'est aux juifs pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
et c'est ce que les serbes nous on fait
avec tous ces massacres l'otan semble
bien avoir repris en main le sort des
réfugiés ici en macédoine mais les
évacuations vont se faire au compte
gouttes
seuls 70 personnes partiront ce soir
pour la norvège un peu plus de 100
partiront demain pour l'allemagne en
attendant les réfugiés reste indésirable
pour les autorités macédoniennes qui
font tout pour précipiter le mouvement
c'est en albanie que l'on compte le plus
grand nombre de réfugiés entre 250 et
300 mille selon les dernières
estimations
bertrand cocq y at-il eu des réactions
annonce de ce cessez le feu prévu par
belgrade à tirana écouter claude pour
l'instant les autorités albanaises n'ont
même pas pris le temps de réagir à
l'annoncé faite à belgrade vous savez
que la priorité ici c'est le poids que
fait peser sur la fragile économie du
pays la présence de vous le disiez ses
quelques 200 250 mille réfugiés du
kosovo et je ne pense pas prendre de
risque en vous disant que les albanais
se montreront certainement bien plus
intéressés par la non ce fait à paris il
ya un instant par le président chirac
d'un plan d'urgence à l'échelle de
l'europe à destination des pays
d'accueil
concernant le cessez le feu unilatéral
annoncé par belgrade l'opinion générale
si tant est qu'elles en soient informés
tiens cela pour une manoeuvre un coup de
bluff du président milosevic ont fait
valoir qu'il a beau jeu de proposer un
cessez-le-feu alors même qu'il a
pratiquement atteint tous ses objectifs
il a presque réussi à vider le kosovo de
ces populations indésirables
il a déstabilisé
la région au prix d'une catastrophe
humanitaire il a même il est même
parvenu à diviser une en partie les
alliés de l'otan sur le meilleur moyen
d'apporter remède à cette catastrophe
humanitaire
vous savez par exemple que les autorités
albanaises sont très défavorables à ces
évacuations vers des pays tiers de
réfugiés tel qu'on a pu le voir
aujourd'hui à partir de la macédoine
bref ici en albanie on reste sur une
ligne dure on est pour la poursuite des
opérations militaires on souhaite même
leur intensification les albanais ont
accepté sur leur sol la présence
d'hélicoptères américains d' attaque au
sol et ils attendent avec impatience le
résultat des frappes de ce soir dont
l'otan nous dit qu'elles seront les plus
importantes depuis le début des
opérations
merci bertrand enfin au monténégro une
équipe de france 2 avec maryse burgot et
gilles jacquier s'est rendu ce matin
dans le nord de ce pays qui fait
toujours partie de la république
fédérale de yougoslavie au nord donc du
monténégro il ya plusieurs milliers de
réfugiés albanais en attente d'une aide
humanitaire
ces hommes ces femmes et ces enfants ne
sont pas des réfugiés
ce sont des déplacés car nous sommes ici
au monténégro une république qui fait
partie de la yougoslavie de milosevic
alors même si c'est albanais honteuse
aussi fui les troupes serbes ils ne sont
pas considérés comme des réfugiés
mais peu importe leur histoire leur
immense détresse et bien la même que
celle des réfugiés d'allemagne ou de
macedo il raconte que les serbes les ont
chassés et qu'ils ont brûlé leurs
maisons
ils disent qu'ils n'ont plus d'espoir et
que dieu seul set aux journaux hmida
tragédie qu'ils ont vécu dans la petite
ville frontalière de rhodes juillet on
les a installés dans les usines les
écoles et les mosquées
35000 personnes logées un peu partout
jusque dans les conteneurs vides les
hommes attendent désoeuvrés à
l'extérieur de ces abris de fortune et
il raconte combien il a fallu verser aux
serbes pour avoir le droit de sortir fin
sans doute marque le plus souvent pour
sauver sa vie l'un d'entre eux explique
on lui a fait payer un prix de gros
qu'un vous offrant 200 personnes la
petite ville de rhodes jahier compte
normalement 25000 personnes
l'arrivée de ces déplacés a évidemment
totalement perturbé les habitudes et
chacun ici de se demander où l'on peut
bien envoyé ses albanais dans ces bus en
partance pour le sud du monténégro
nous avons rencontré des hommes et des
femmes qui n'avaient aucune idée de
l'endroit où ils allaient les visages
des gares et ne trouvant pas les mots
pour envisager un avenir alors que nous
quittions rejaillit
sirène d' alerte aux bombardements
retentissait pour la énième fois
car ici au monténégro ces déplacés sont
certes à l'abri des serbes mais pas à
l'abri des bombardements de l'otan
maryse burgot à podgorica la capitale du
monténégro quelles sont les réactions
vous avez pu recueillir après cette
annonce de cessez-le-feu unilatéral et
bien écoutez nous avons après que le
président du monténégro et ans et est en
ce moment en réunion de crise à ce sujet
pas d'informations pour l'instant mais
il est à prévoir que les autorités de ce
pays se montreront très prudente après
la proposition de slobodan milosevic
vous savez que le monténégro est une
petite république qui fait partie de
l'eau et de la yougoslavie
mais c'est une petite république qui a
pris ses distances par rapport à ce logo
dan milosevic
l'actuel président a même dit à
plusieurs reprises qu'il n'avait aucune
confiance en la parole de slobodan
milosevic
c'est dire à quel point la proposition
de minots évident ce sera ici prise avec
beaucoup de circonspection
quoi qu'il en soit ici on aimerait
beaucoup qu'un cessez-le-feu
interviennent entre lui ces cas et les
serbes
on aimerait surtout beaucoup que les
bombardements de l'otan cessent vous
savez qui c'est l'antenne et gros les
frappes de l'est l'otan a frappé à trois
reprises des sites stratégiques
merci maryse la france avait fait savoir
dès hier qu'elle préférait une aide sur
place se réfugier plutôt qu'un transfert
de ceux ci vers d'autres pays transfert
futile temporaire pour monsieur jospin
il ne faut pas jouer le jeu de monsieur
milosevic qui veut réduire ou supprimer
la présence des albanais au kosovo mais
cet après midi à l'assemblée nationale
le premier ministre a dû préciser
certains aspects de la position
française pour ne pas apparaître faire
cavalier seul dans la gestion
humanitaire des réfugiés
notre pays est naturellement disponible
pour accueillir temporairement sur son
sol un certain nombre de ces personnes
déplacées
mais il souhaite que ces mouvements de
réfugiés s'effectue sur la base du
volontariat et sans que les personnes et
sans que les familles soient séparés
conformément au droit humanitaire
international
n'ajoutons pas
n'ajoutons pas un transfert contraint à
une déportation
comme je les dis dimanche soir au terme
d'une réunion de travail que j'avais
organisée à matignon
nous pourrons accueillir utilisant pour
cela
l'asile territoriale institut les
instituts et il y a quelques mois par le
parlement sur proposition du
gouvernement
oui nous pourrons accueillir des
réfugiés qui en ferait la demande
et le premier ministre a rappelé les
différents points d'un accord tel qui
fut rédigeait rambouillet accord
prévenir non seulement le cessez le feu
mais le retrait des forces serbes le
retour des réfugiés et l'application
dudit accord de rambouillet à
l'assemblée nationale l'accueil a été
mitigé et puis quelques heures après son
intervention
les députés apprenait la proposition
faite par les autorités de belgrade
voici quelques réactions recueillies par
j'évite imbert et lætitia legendre
discrétion et même silence en attendant
d'en savoir plus c'est la ligne adoptée
pour l'instant aussi bien par le
ministre des affaires étrangères que par
celui de la défense
hubert védrine et alain richard ont
réservé leurs commentaires et sans doute
aussi leurs informations aux députés
réunis en commission
en fait l'annoncé par belgrade ce soir
d'un cessez-le-feu au kosovo est d'abord
accueilli avec le plus grand scepticisme
si ça signifie un arrêt des opérations
militaires policières à l'encontre de la
communauté que ce bar sis à 6 cela je
n'en suis pas sûr je pense que c'est une
une bonne chose et que ça va dans le
sens de préparer un plan de règlement
international mais tout ceci est très
conditionnel optimisme très mesuré donc
et surtout beaucoup de prudence c'est
également la tonalité des premiers
commentaires au sein de l'opposition
les raids de l'otan commencent à avoir
un résultat
la cohésion de milosevic sur sur la
cohésion de son art mais aussi je pense
que naturellement cette offre de
cessez-le-feu ne trompera personne
comment oser parler de cessez-le-feu
quand on vient d'expulser un demi
million de personnes par la violence
dans les conditions que l'on sait pour
les communistes en revanche belgrade
vient de franchir un pas important ce
soir selon le pc c'est l'otan qui est au
pied du mur
je regrette profondément l'attitude
unilatérale de bill clinton de dire
d'emblée que c'est absolument pas à
prendre en compte cette proposition
rejetant purement et simplement les
choses sans consulter ses alliés sans
que la france ait son mot à dire dans
cette affaire je trouve là vraiment que
nous sommes au paroxysme d'une mise sous
tutelle c'est inacceptable avant
d'écouter l'intervention de jacques
chirac les députés se sont expliqués à
huis clos
quoi qu'il arrive le débat en france
qu'on est lui aussi un tournant alors
gérard leclerc revenons sur
l'intervention du président de la
république sa deuxième intervention sans
générer très sobrement une volonté
d'explication et un discours très ferme
oui absolument un ton qui était celui de
la fermeté de la détermination la
fermeté en réponse aux différentes
critiques que l'on a pu entendre le
présent dans les pubs etc a justifié une
nouvelle fois l'intervention militaire
face je le cite à la monstrueuse
opération d'épuration ethnique planifiée
au kosovo les termes utilisés par le
chef de l'état sont particulièrement
durs milosevic est qualifié de dictateur
les mots de cynisme de cruauté et de
barbarie ont été prononcées et puis
jacques chirac a également répondu sur
lac sur l'aide humanitaire
elle est à l'oeuvre at il dit la france
y prend toute sa part mais comme le
premier ministre le chef de l'état n'est
pas partisan d'un transfert massif des
kosovars vers les pays occidentaux en
les éloignant de chez eux at il dit on
ferait le jeu de milosevic
en revanche les pays européens se
réuniront nous at-il dès le 14 avril
pour décider des aides aux pays voisins
du kosovo uck qui accueille ses réfugiés
et puis le plaisir de la république a
réagi à cette offre de cessez-le-feu
unilatéral fait par belgrade vers 17
heures ou après midi il l'a qualifiée
d'indispensable et d'insuffisances et
d'ailleurs exactement les termes
qu'avait utilisé quelques minutes
auparavant
en allemagne gerhard schröder et faire
monsieur utilisé par monsieur d'alema en
italie absolument donc il ya une
parfaite unité de ton entre les
différents pays de l'alliance
le cessez-le-feu a précisé le chef
d'état doit respecter les conditions qui
ont été rappelées cet après-midi par
lionel jospin
donc les deux sont exactement sur la
même ligne la fin des représailles au
kosovo le retrait des troupes serbes le
retour des réfugiés et l'acceptation des
négociations la france autrement a dit
présence d'un public continuera à
rechercher avec les européens les
américains les russes et sous l'autorité
de l'onu qui est ainsi un peu
réintroduit dans le jeu et bien
continuera à rechercher une solution
politique
des réunions du groupe de contact ou du
g8 avec les russes sont à l'étude mais
en attendant les frappes continuent on
lui dit que même elles seront
intensifiés cette nuit oui et même une
alerte aérienne qui devrait déclencher à
belgrade la capitale serbe et pour
conclure provisoirement ce chapitre de
la qualité relatifs aux frappes de
l'otan au kosovo
il convient de signaler les préparatifs
de départ pour des détachements de
pompiers dans les différents
départements du sud est de la france
il doit se rendre en macédoine et en
albanie à partir de la base militaire
d'istres
tandisque des véhicules embarquerait sur
des bâtiments militaires à toulon et
puis je vous rappelle les coordonnées de
la croix rouge que france télévisions a
décidé de supporter croix rouge
française réfugiés kosovo bp 300 75008
paris pour vos dons pour aider la croix
rouge a supporté le sort des réfugiés du
kosovo qui se trouve donc en macédoine
en albanie et au monténégro à la haye
aux pays bas les deux libyens suspectés
d'être les auteurs de l'attentât commis
contre l'avion de la panam en décembre
88 ont comparu ce matin devant un juge
de nationalité écossaise car c'est selon
la procédure particulière écossaise qui
vont être interrogés pendant plusieurs
mois avant d'être éventuellement jugé m
dans le dossier d'accusation il ya aussi
le dossier de l'avion du téat et les
familles des faits des victimes
françaises demandent à ne pas être
oublié reportage de joël bruandet et
alice vêtu l'heure
les deux agents libyens ont été
transférés dans la soirée d'hier au camp
2 ait une base aérienne désaffectée mise
à la disposition des autorités
écossaises pour toute la durée du procès
mais abdelbaset al megrahi est à la
minera l'ifa fahima ne seront pas jugée
avant plusieurs mois
les deux hommes sont soupçonnés d'être à
l'origine de l'attentât commis en 89
contre le boeing de la panam attentat
qui avait tué 270 personnes
dès hier l'onu a suspendu les sanctions
qui frappaient la libye depuis cette
date pour une levée définitive de ces
sanctions il faudra néanmoins attendre
un vote du conseil de sécurité d'ici
trois mois
pourtant les états unis ont choisi de
maintenir leurs propres sanctions contre
la libye
par ailleurs les résolutions de l'onu
prévoyait également une coopération de
la libye dans le dossier du dc 10 d'uta
autres attentats qui avaient fait en 89
170 morts en france certaines voix
s'élèvent aujourd'hui et refuse que l'on
oublie le volet français du dossier
il n'est pas question en mémoire des 170
morts que les sanctions puissent être
levés avant que la libye respecte ses
engagements vis-à-vis des 170 morts d'un
avion français - marc kadhafi s'était en
effet engagé il y a trois ans à se
conformer à une décision de la justice
française
or il y a trois semaines au procès du dc
10 d'uta la cour d'assises de paris a
condamné par contumace six
fonctionnaires libyens à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
c'est précisément cette décision de
justice que la france souhaite voir
appliquer dès que possible
à colmar les magistrats de la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel ont
décidé de maintenir en prison monsieur
françois supéry l'ancien directeur de
l'association cheval pour tous ni un
examen pour agressions sexuelles les
mauvais traitements sur mineure mais le
dossier d'accusation semble se modifier
reportage jérôme soûlard et sylvain
gauthier une demande de remise en
liberté rejetée par la cour d'appel de
colmar
une déception pour les avocats de
françois supéry pour la défense les
éléments de contestation du dossier
d'accusation ne manquent pourtant pas
exemple les victimes elles seraient une
dizaine pour le procureur bof moi
selon les avocats net il ya les victimes
aux yeux de l'accusation qui ont été
auditionnées et qui viennent dire ben
non moi je me plains de rien du tout
bien et qui infirme totalement la thèse
de l'accusation et d'autre part autres
catégories
il y a il via les victimes n'ont encore
auditionner dont on ignore le point de
vue et qui cependant dès à présent son
catalogue et par le parquet comme étant
les victimes de françois supéry alors
c'est quand même une situation un peu
saugrenue en fait seuls deux anciens
pensionnaires de l'association
aujourd'hui majeurs accuserait
explicitement françois supéry de viol
devant le juge d'instruction
l'un des accusateurs est revenu à deux
reprises sur ses propos avant
d'expliquer clairement ses motivations
ce jeune qui est revenu sur sa
déclaration en fait a effectivement et
textuellement dis moi j'ai fait ça
c'était un coup monté qui a déclenché
comme il le dit lui même
j'étais la mèche dans le briquet et puis
je savais qu'une fois que la mèche se
rallumer bien il y aurait les
déclarations et puis que je pourrais
faire tomber ce ticket
l'instruction de ce dossier très délicat
devrait durer une bonne année car pour
l'instant seuls les témoins à charge
contre françois super y ont été entendus
d'autres témoins plus favorable à
l'association attend donc aujourd'hui de
pouvoir donner leur version des faits et
administrations préfectorale elle n'a
pas attendu plus longtemps il y a
quelques jours elle a ordonné la
fermeture de l'établissement et le
départ immédiat de tous ses
pensionnaires des mineurs délinquants
récidivistes
les conseils d'administration de la
société générale paribas avait à se
prononcer aujourd'hui sur l'offre
publique d'échangé faite par la bnp
déjà le conseil d'administration de la
société générale a rejeté à l'unanimité
moins une voix
l'opéra de la bnp et on attend ce soir
la position de paribas
et qui doit ainsi donc répondre aux
souhaits de la bnp de racheter paribas
et la société générale pour devenir
ainsi leader dans ce monde de la finance
reportage jean-paul chapelle et j'ai
encore dû pas de commentaire ni à
l'entrée ni à la sortie
pourtant le conseil d'administration de
la société générale a forcément été très
animée c'est la première riposte légale
à l'offensive de la bnp en présence du
plus chauds partisans de la bnp
le patron d'axa claude bébéar comment
s'est passé le conseil le sport c'est
donc à l'unanimité moins une voix qui a
été rejeté l'offre publique des changes
de la bnp
face à elle la résistance s'organise
inséparables depuis le 1er février les
patrons de la société générale et de
paribas ne veulent pas entendre parler
d'une fusion à trois je rappelle que
société générale les réseaux de détail
ont une rentabilité sur fonds propres
une rentabilité par employé un chiffre
d'affaires par employés qui sont très
sensiblement supérieurs à ceux de la bnb
pourquoi est ce que il faudrait que les
actionnaires société générale souhaite
avoir un rapprochement d'agents ce qui
est peut-être une bonne idée pour la bnp
mais qui n'est sûrement pas une bonne
idée pour les actionnaires de la société
générale les actionnaires ont encore 25
jours pour choisir entre les deux
schémas une bataille boursière en
perspective une bataille de
communication également
qui ne fait que commencer en sport il
faut savoir que le rallye auto-moto
paris-dakar deviendra pour son édition
de l'an 2001 paris dakar le caire avec
départ effectif le 6 janvier de la
capitale du sénégal et une arrivée en
egypte le 23 janvier 2000 le tout sur
france télévision cinéma demain sur les
écrans un premier film intitulé babel
réalisé par gérard pullicino gérard
pullicino c'est le complice de nagui
pour taratata que vous aurez le bonheur
de retrouver sur france 2 dès vendredi
prochain et à 20h50
mais pour son premier film long métrage
que les tino propose un conte
fantastique pour les enfants
représentation
stéphane haumant et jean louis malle
quatre portes qui gardent la pierre de
la tour de babel depuis les mineurs
une pierre mystérieuse qui peut rendre
maîtres du monde trois créatures poilues
venu des entrailles de la terre un petit
surdoué des jeux vidéo et son verre
azimuts et babel ressemble à une bande
dessinée
marche sur et l'humour et ça fait des
petits michel jonasz retrait au cinéma
après 15 ans un film pour les petits
tourné avec de gros moyens
des centaines de figurants cette semaine
de tournage au canada et toutes les
scènes jouées en deux langues pour
l'exportation
c'est pas le problème de jouer en
anglais qui est difficile mais c'est
d'enchaîner tout de suite des versions
anglaises version française tout de
suite tout de suite après parce que
c'est quand même une autre une autre
façon de parler et presque une autre
façon de bouger aussi pullicino le
réalisateur mélange clin d'oeil à la
série la quatrième dimension et
références à la bible il idolâtre le
film iti et ça se voit
ap récents clips musicaux
l'enregistrement de show de bowie ou
johnny des émissions télé pullicino se
met à son compte et passe au cinéma
j'ai toujours voulu faire ça et par la
force des choses et j'ai fait de la télé
et je reviens mais pour les amours faire
du cinéma c'est un rêve de gosse
oui un rêve de gosse qui ressemble
beaucoup à un cauchemar
des angoisses de fin du monde un peu
naïve à la veille de l'an 2000 mais
comme dans tous les contes l'avenir
appartient aux âmes d'enfant nous
arrivons à la fin de cette édition je
vous rappelle les différentes
informations concernant l'opération de
frappe des alliés de l'otan au kosovo
tout d'abord l'offre de sel c'est
l'annoncé d'un cessez le feu unilatéral
au kosovo annonce faite à belgrade est
en forme de réponse notamment dans
l'intervention du président de la
république à 20 heures celle ci c'est
nécessaire mais insuffisant a dit
monsieur chirac comme plusieurs
responsables européens les frappes donc
continue ce soir encore alerté argana
belgrade tandis que les réfugiés se
comptent maintenant par centaines de
milliers de personnes
quelques réfugiés refuse de repartir
vers d'autres destinations que le kosovo
il ya donc tension en macédoine mais
actuellement l'aide humanitaire
s'organise sur place en albanie en
macédoine est un peu moins au monténégro
car la situation du monténégro est
particulière elle fait toujours partie
de la république fédérale de yougoslavie
dans quelques secondes la météo avec
sophie davant et puis à 29 55 batman
suivi de classe de la république
le dernier journal de la 1100 présentée
par laurence ostolaza suivi du cercle de
philippe lefait qui raconte m jean rouch
demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra monsieur
dimitrieff king porte parole du
président boris eltsine a envie plex de
moscou à 13h vous trouverez rachid arhab
à demain 20h bonsoir